ok we're going to have more about this
next topic coming up next week so I
don't want to spend a ton of time on it
but I think given the events of the last
seven days it bears mention if we've
learned anything over the last seven
days
yes we've confirmed that Donald Trump
can't lead but we knew that but we've
also gotten reinforcement that Donald
Trump is not going to go peacefully if
he loses to Joe Biden in November now
I've said before this is not some
ominous conspiracy theory where Donald
Trump will be able to stay in power
indefinitely like a king I continue to
believe that if Donald Trump loses in
November he will leave you will leave
eventually but he's going to do it under
protest and it's not going to be what we
traditionally think of as a peaceful
transition of power remember he won in
2016 and has been arguing that it was
rigged against him okay he won and has
spent three years saying the results
can't be trusted Yale forensic
psychiatrist dr. bandy Lee is now
warning that the shows of strength and
really the shows of false strength false
displays of strength from Donald Trump
over the last week foreshadow his likely
behavior if he loses the 20/20 election
so when we say false displays of
strength we mean the Bible photo-op the
tweets and statements about sending in
the military his obvious lie that he
didn't go to the bunker for protection
on Friday he went to inspect the bunker
give me a break dude the idea is that
all of these completely transparent
shows of supposed strength are Trump
laying the framework for continuing to
build a legitimate power so that later
in five months
he will question the results of the
election here's another example blaming
the protests on an Tifa in order to try
to disqualify the overwhelmingly
peaceful protesters and they're
completely respectable and and real
motives for protesting so it's
interesting to see a psychiatrist put a
name to it but the reaction from anybody
who's been paying attention is well yeah
Trump has been laying the groundwork to
complain about the upcoming election
results for a long time Democrats can
only win if they cheat that's another
that Trump has been using off and on for
the last year Trump has slowly been
ratcheting up the authoritarianism
culminating so far Monday with his
threat to send in the military against
the demands of Governors even these
little authoritarian slides tighten his
grip a tiny bit his priority has always
been personal power and we have to be
prepared for him to challenge the
results in November and this is not
about martial law this is not about
suspending elections and declaring
himself King I believe he will go but we
have to ensure that our institutions are
actually prepared to remove him when it
happens and it may not even you know
even remove suggests someone's going to
show up by force and remove Trump it's
more that our institutions just have to
make it abundantly clear that if his
term is ending his term is ending and if
he's not reelect 'add someone else is
coming in and that's it and I still
don't believe that there's gonna be any
removal by force and I don't want to be
a broken record but he won and
questioned the results he won and
questioned the results in November of
2016 just imagine what will happen if he
loses let me know what you expect in
November on Twitter where you can find
me at D Pakman you can also get the
daily audio podcast of the show for free
on your favorite podcasting app whether
it's iTunes Spotify Pandora Google Play
podcasts stitcher really whatever you
want get the podcast let me know your
thoughts about Trump and November on
Twitter at D Pakman we have a packed
show in store for you today